[Musica]
per noi tutti penso di non sbagliarmi è
importante conoscere il mondo che ci
circonda il mondo in cui viviamo capire
come è fatto come lo spazio Come sono
gli oggetti ma all'interno di questa
comprensione credo che ancora più
importante sia capire cosa fanno gli
altri cosa provano gli altri
come possiamo interagire con loro per
esempio comunicare conversare cooperare
giocare e anche perché no imitare quello
che fanno se sono più bravi di noi in
certe capacità ecco tutto questo è
quello che noi chiamiamo tecnicamente
cognizione sociale e adesso sappiamo da
diversi anni che
la cognizione sociale supportata e
spiegata da un meccanismo neurale che va
sotto il nome di sistema specchio
però per capire come il sistema a
specchio dobbiamo prima capire
l'importanza del sistema motorio perché
per tanti anni si è creduto soprattutto
nel secolo scorso che per arrivare alla
conoscenza del mondo Noi dobbiamo fare
una elaborazione di quello che ci viene
dai nostri sensi o l'elaborazione di
alto livello che ci fa arrivare alla
percezione Dopodiché questo dato Lo
sfruttiamo per muoverci lo forniamo il
nostro sistema che controlla il
movimento per agire però capite che con
questa visione il sistema motorio è un
sistema a servizio non è un sistema
fondamentale per la conoscenza
ma invece gli studi sia comportamentali
che anatomici che neurofisiologici degli
ultimi 30 anni ci hanno fatto vedere che
le cose stanno in una maniera un po'
diversa cioè il sistema motorio è alla
base della nostra costruzione della
conoscenza e se noi pensiamo al
movimento pensiamo a tutto quello che
possiamo fare con il nostro corpo in
particolare a le nostre ai nostri
movimenti più sofisticati come per
esempio quelli della mano ecco Questi
sono quelli che appunto ci aiutano a
costruirci la conoscenza del mondo
e vorrei solamente farvi un esempio per
dimostrare come questo si può far vedere
oggettivamente
dallo studio dei neuroni motori che si
trovano nel primate non umano ricaviamo
proprio queste dimostrazioni qui vedete
tre eventi comportamentali un primato
non umano che prende del cibo con la
bocca con la mano destra e con la mano
sinistra Ecco tre movimenti di tipo
diverso che hanno in comune però la
stessa cosa afferrare Ebbene questo
neurone questo singolo neurone si attiva
in tutte e tre le situazioni Il che vuol
dire che
questo neurone
dice qualcosa di molto elevato un'idea
motoria che l'idea della ferramenta La
ferramenta è uno scopo quindi un neurone
un neurone singolo ci dice Qual è il
nostro scopo e lo studio di tanti
neuroni di questo tipo ci ha fatto
vedere che nella nostra corteccia esiste
una memoria dei nostri scopi motori che
noi utilizziamo tutte le volte che
vogliamo agire ma ce li possiamo anche
solo rappresentare mentalmente provate a
pensare se
immaginate di fare qualcosa immaginate
di afferrare non fate niente però nella
nostra mente vi assicuro si sta
attivando il sistema motorio quindi
chiaramente è un sistema mentale questo
non è affatto un sistema puramente per
l'esecuzione del movimento
e è proprio da questo che dobbiamo
partire per capire come avviene la
nostra conoscenza del mondo la nostra
conoscenza primaria
noi sappiamo da studi sofisticati e
fatti con un'ecografia ad alta
dimensione che
il feto già dalla 22esima settimana di
gestazione in avanti compie una serie di
movimenti che non sono affatto movimenti
casuali Ma hanno la struttura di Quei
movimenti che fa l'adulti i movimenti
finalizzati quindi capite nasciamo con
un sistema un repertorio motorio Già
pronto alla nascita per cominciare a
conoscere il mondo
conoscerlo delimitando lo spazio intorno
a noi afferrando automaticamente gli
oggetti e quindi conoscendo il mondo in
maniera motoria i sensi Poi quando si
svilupperanno ci confermeranno quello
che sappiamo già in maniera motoria
e è proprio da questo che dobbiamo
partire per capire come funziona il
sistema specchio
perché i neuroni specchio sono neuroni
motori primariamente vorrei spiegargli
partendo proprio da come sono stati
scoperti
studiando il laboratorio le proprietà di
neuroni motori di una certa area
e quindi per fare questo interagendo con
un primate non umano a cui si
proponevano degli oggetti si facevano
dei movimenti degli atti finalizzati di
fronte a questo primate a un certo punto
ci si accorge che i neuroni si attivano
quando il primate vede qualcosa che noi
facciamo degli atti che stiamo facendo e
se all'inizio è stato una cosa un po'
sorprendente Per noi è stato possibile
però spiegarlo rapidamente con tutta la
conoscenza che avevamo precedentemente
appunto sulle proprietà cognitive del
sistema motorio
quindi molto semplicemente i neuroni
specchio sono dei neuroni che si
attivano sia quando un primate non umano
svolge un atto di afferramento per
esempio oppure quando lo osserva fatto
da un altro individuo sia su una scimmia
oppure un essere umano capite un
meccanismo molto semplice però da questo
meccanismo molto semplice nasce la
cognizione sociale
e i neuroni specchio sono stati studiati
in molti dei loro dettagli quindi adesso
sappiamo molto sulle loro
caratteristiche ma una cosa è
fondamentale per arrivare
all'interpretazione cioè il fatto che si
devono attivare in maniera congruente
sia quando si svolge un determinato atto
motorio l'esecuzione sia quando si
osserva lo stesso atomotorio
osservazione
perché in questo modo i neuroni fanno
una comparazione tra l'atto osservato e
lato eseguito e da questa comparazione
emerge una comprensione automatica di
quello che fanno gli altri senza bisogno
di pensarci capite il meccanismo
semplice adattativo costituito da questi
neuroni e non solo la comprensione non
avviene solo in base all'osservazione Ma
anche in base all'ascolto provate a
pensare se sentite qualcuno in una
stanza vicino che stappano bottiglia di
spumante dal Solo rumore Voi capite che
corrisponde un determinato atto
capite lo scopo di quell'atto quindi sia
che sia osservazione sia che sia ascolto
però l'importante è accedere al
significato che un significato motorio
ora
naturalmente viene ovvia la domanda Ma
esiste questo sistema nell'uomo Beh
chiaramente l'uomo è il frutto di una
filogenesi che parte dalla scimmia e
quindi siccome noi siamo capaci di
comprendere quello che facciamo gli
altri Ovviamente pensiamo di avere
questo sistema però bisogna dimostrarlo
ed è stato dimostrato attraverso delle
tecniche sia di tipo elettrofisiologico
sia di neuroimmagine nuove tecniche
introdotte una trentina di anni fa che
ci permettono di vedere come si attiva
il cervello umano quando svolge
determinati compiti e quindi in questo
modo si è capito che quando dei soggetti
osservano degli altri che svolgono degli
atti con la bocca con la mano con il
piede si attivano queste regioni in
colore della corteccia frontale e della
corteccia parietale che costituiscono
nel loro insieme il sistema motorio
queste regioni sono corrispondenti a
quelle che nel primate non umano
contengono i neuroni specchio Quindi
adesso tutta una serie di dati ormai
robuste ci conferma la presenza di
questo sistema nell'uomo ma sorgono
anche altre domande per esempio se
questo sistema è nato
Esiste la nascita già o nel bambino
Oppure si matura con l'esperienza e non
abbiamo una risposta definitiva questa
domanda perché è anche difficile fare
gli esperimenti sui piccoli ma
esperimenti fatti per esempio i bambini
anche fino a 6 mesi
hanno mostrato che quando un piccolo
osserva un atto motore per esempio un
raggiungimento E quando lo fa in tutti e
due i casi si attiva la sua corteccia
motoria vedete si vengono registrati con
sistemi non invasivi queste cuffiette le
trecce fanografiche Quindi anche questo
è andato estremamente interessante
come potete capire il meccanismo
specchio aperto numerosi filoni di
ricerca lo studio della comprensione
delle intenzioni altrui la comprensione
del linguaggio limitazione e tra queste
ce n'è una che particolarmente
importante la comprensione delle
emozioni Le emozioni le potremmo
chiamare un po' le azioni calde da un
certo punto di vista le altre che
abbiamo visto finora le possiamo
chiamare le azioni fredde Ebbene come
Comprendiamo l'emozione degli altri dal
punto di vista nostro sappiamo che
esiste un circuito neurale che è
implicato nella consapevolezza e nella
espressione delle nostre emozioni
per esempio l'aumento del battito
cardiaco la variazione respiratoria la
liberazione di adrenalina Qui sono tutti
effetti dovuti alle emozioni ovviamente
e si conosce molto bene questo circuito
però comprendere il meccanismo che ci
permette di capire le emozioni altrui E
un'altra cosa
sicuramente uno strumento privilegiato
per l'uomo è quello di osservare
un'espressione emotiva E da questo punto
di vista ci aiuta molto il lavoro di
Hackman che ha dimostrato come ci sono 6
emozioni fondamentali alcune negative
alcune positive a cui corrispondono
altrettante espressioni facciali poi ci
sono anche delle espressioni combinate
tra emozioni differenti Ecco Uno
potrebbe pensare che si capiscono le
emozioni perché si etichettano
determinate espressioni Questo vuol dire
Gioia questa vuol dire tristezza
eccetera
e quindi in un sistema un po' di tipo
deduttivo riflessivo l'altra possibilità
invece è che noi Comprendiamo le
emozioni degli altri perché in qualche
modo ci mettiamo nei panni degli altri
l'espressione molto usata ma vediamo
cosa significa dal punto di vista dei
neuroni mettersi nei panni degli altri
Vi faccio una sola sull'esempio di uno
studio che è stato fatto sul disgusto
che è un'emozione particolarmente
importante per esempio in un animale
vedere una faccia disgustata di un altro
animale vuol dire che c'è del cibo
probabilmente nocivo quindi molto
importante da un punto di vista
adattativo ma è importante anche per noi
naturalmente Ebbene in questo studio
c'era una prima condizione in cui i
soggetti dovevano odorare degli odoranti
o spiacevoli come per esempio uova marce
oppure piacevole come ad esempio il
profumo di rose e in un'altra condizione
invece osservavano esiste espressioni di
attori che
odorando da un bicchiere facevano finta
di fare un'espressione di disgusto o di
piacere Quindi le stesse cose
corrispondenti a quelle del soggetto che
osservava Ebbene
Come si attiva il cervello in queste
condizioni la cosa più importante da
andare a vedere è se ci sono delle
attivazioni congiunte E infatti è stato
trovato che ci sono delle aree quelle
che vedete in bianco che si attivano sia
Quando il soggetto prova disgusto sia
quando lo osserva nella faccia
disgustata dell'attore le stesse
identiche regioni che sono le regioni di
una zona che si chiama insula
inizialmente non si sapeva far parte del
sistema emotivo ma adesso si capisce che
è molto importante per la nostra
consapevolezza degli stati d'animo e
delle emozioni pensate che ci sono dei
pazienti che hanno una lesione lavoro in
questa regione e che non sono capaci di
provare disgusto E non sono neanche
capace di capire il disgusto
nell'espressione degli altri ma
contemporaneamente sono capaci di capire
le espressioni di rabbia di paura
eccetera quindi è proprio una regione
molto specifica insieme a un'altra zona
che si chiama cingolo anteriore di cui
si sa già da tempo che è implicata nel
sistema emotivo Quindi come interpretare
questo dato che è molto importante
noi possiamo dire che è un sistema
simile a quello delle azioni come per le
azioni Noi praticamente mappiamo le
emozioni degli altri sulle stesse aree
che si attivano quando siamo noi a
provare quelle emozioni quindi è come se
in qualche modo riprovassimo quelle
emozioni e in questo modo lo
Comprendiamo
teniamo conto che questo tipo di
rispecchiamento è anch'esso di natura
motoria perché l'insula che vi ho
nominato prima è una regione che
controlla direttamente il battito
cardiaco il respiro anche il sistema
gastrointestinale solo che è un sistema
motorio un po' particolare Controlla i
visceri però il meccanismo è esattamente
dello stesso di quello che vi ho
descritto per le azioni
quindi Comprendiamo le emozioni mediante
un meccanismo di rispecchiamento e a
questo punto c'è da fare una
considerazione come molte ricerche di
base
quando si va avanti nella ricerca si
cerca di incrementare la conoscenza non
ci si pone magari tanto il problema
della possibile applicabilità
ma molto spesso viene da sé questo come
è successo nel caso del sistema a
specchio per esempio adesso noi sappiamo
che esistono delle possibili
applicazioni nella nostra conoscenza sul
meccanismo di rispecchiamento per
esempio nella comprensione di alcune
sindromi della cognizione sociale come
ad esempio l'autismo nei bambini
autistici in cui il nocciolo centrale è
un problema di interazione sociale di
comprensione anche delle intenzioni
credenze emozioni degli altri Ebbene è
stato visto che c'è probabilmente una
organizzazione Non completamente
normale del sistema motorio
questo è stato ovviamente dimostrato con
numerose tecniche e questo ci porta a
dire quindi che se il sistema motorio
non è così organizzato come nei bambini
a sviluppo tipico di conseguenza anche
il sistema a specchio non riesce a
essere così funzionante e quindi a
permettere una comprensione
l'interazione sociale corretta
nello stesso tempo ci sono anche
applicazioni che ci permettono di
intervenire in termini terapeutici per
cui
il sistema specchio ancora funzionante
può essere utilizzato per migliorare la
performance motoria di particolari tipi
di pazienti per esempio pazienti adulti
come
quelli che hanno subito un attacco
ischemico e quindi hanno magari una
quaresi motoria oppure addirittura
parkinsoniani o pazienti giovani con
paralisi cerebrale infantile che sono
quei pazienti che hanno subito una
lesione prenatale e nascono con problemi
di tipo A volte cognitivo ma molto
spesso di tipo motorio Ecco in tutti
questi pazienti si può fare una terapia
di alcune settimane basata sulla
osservazione e immediata riproduzione
delle azioni via via sempre più
complesse e quello che si è trovato e
che soggetti Ognuno di questi pazienti
migliora la sua prestazione motoria e in
parallelo Si può dimostrare che a
livello cerebrale ci sono delle
modificazioni delle attivazioni
cerebrali dopo la terapia che spiegano
Come mai C'è stato questo miglioramento
motorio Quindi adesso abbiamo anche
l'evidenza neurale della possibilità di
riabilitare un evidenza di un cervello
plastico
ora questi sono solamente degli spunti
potete capire come lo studio del sistema
specchio possa aprirsi a numerosi altri
studi per esempio di altre patologie sto
pensando ad esempio la schizofrenia in
questo problema dell'identificazione del
sé e dell'altro ad esempio oppure la
sindrome della Tourette in cui abbiamo
questo problema delle imitazione
automatica dei movimenti fatti da un
altro o pensate addirittura la
possibilità di dimostrare la presenza di
un sistema specchio residuo in malati in
pazienti in minima coscienza
Ecco tutte queste sono delle possibili
aperture nuove ricerche come d'altronde
lo sono
negli individui sani pensate per esempio
a tutto lo studio sul meccanismo
imitativo come noi facciamo ad
apprendere per imitazione Questo apre
tutto un altro campo per esempio nello
studio dello Sport della danza della
dello studio degli strumenti musicali
eccetera quindi come potete capire la
ricerca sul sistema specchio Certamente
ben lungi dall'essere finita e si
propone di andare avanti per ancora
molti anni
Grazie
[Applauso]